[Music]
when you work with archaeological
objects you are like entering the world
of your ancestors I like to think that
in a way they talk to us
a capo is an accounting device made of
cotton strings that used not to
represent numbers a people is the
accountants of life that peoples were
made in Inca times by typical miles the
key become a ox the only ones who were
able to read it died and didn't pass the
knowledge to the next generations
there's a lot of questions still to get
answered my biggest hope for incahuasi
is to be able to excavate all the site
the clues are very well preserved
because the environment of the Peruvian
coast is very arid so you have a very
good preservation of any organic romaine
this must be 600 years old and you can
see the preservation very well we know
the number we found in the kibbutz are
the counts of these products they have
been varied for 600 years and so what we
do is the conservation that means keep
them a clean and straight so the
analyzer can come and study them
I think this discovery will bring a
better understanding of kibbles and also
in how the Incas dominate and control
these local populations many people say
that because we had no writing no our
culture was not developed no but we
really have things like peoples that
show that it was a very developed
culture every time is exciting because
we are finding them in different
contexts and in different situations and
different sizes different shapes colors
not so we can have a very big data of
this kippa so we got comparing and get
any kind of insight to see how to read
them or how to understand them
the first one when you see them like
really dirty a spaghetti and then at the
end no they're just like take me a
picture no they're so pretty
I think the hippos are grateful
[Music]
[Music]